both of my parents are immigrants from
mexico and the immigrant experience for
me is parallel to what education should
be about right which is if you have a
set of opportunities available to you
there should be as few barriers as
possible to allow you to progress in
society
my name is felix torrano 26 years old
co-founder and ceo of a company called
emil learning
[Music]
best way to understand what a meal
learning does is we're building the
netflix of high school education
the vision is that a student anywhere in
the world should be able to access any
imaginable course anytime anywhere we
have the technology in 2021 to make that
happen
education hasn't changed in a long time
and
the effects of you know this outdated
system really became obvious or evident
during the pandemic where we fit in is
saying how can we fix some of these
issues in education around accessibility
and making the best courses available to
everyone regardless of what local
resources are available to them
[Music]
i've been obsessed with education for a
really long time i went through public
school in la massive system really messy
really complex a lot of people have been
in you know have gone through that
system in my case sort of had a front
row seat to it right and that's inspired
a lot of our sort of ambition for the
scale that we're shooting for
ultimately i think you know education is
so important for society because it's
one of these areas of society where
if one sort of segment of the population
is more educated everyone wins right and
if we have you know all these courses
and
the ability for somebody to progress in
a very tangible way that should be
accessible to everyone so
you know five years from now we hope to
be in as many households as possible in
a way that lets any student in the world
progress at their own pace
[Music]
you